you are looking at a quadratic so your
normal first strategy is to try and
start with the letter F you're trying to
factorize right so you're thinking of
that pair of numbers that multiplies to
in this case multiplies to negative
negative six and adds to negative four
now I only can think of one at six or
two and three neither of which do the
job for me
so being that I cannot factorize quickly
or easily what are my next options what
my next option is I could complete the
square or I could use the formula now
have a look in this case there actually
is a clear one of the two that's better
when we complete the square what we're
used to seeing is a monic quadratic so
we don't expect the number out here or
we expect the number to be one okay so
since you've got a value for a and B and
C that are all messy numbers I think the
easiest way to go here is the quadratic
formula okay now the hardest thing about
the quadratic formula is remembering it
so to give you a bit of an idea because
a little tone you br-2 yet let's see if
we can recite it together you're finding
solutions for X so it begins
x equals it starts with minus b and then
what plus or minus just pause before you
tell me the next bit why is there + n -
that's weird it's because when you take
the square root you get two answers a
positive and a negative okay speaking of
which square root what's underneath b
squared minus 4ac all divided by okay so
now you all have the quadratic formula
okay you will remember it better and
better the more you use it you just need
to know what a and B and C are equal to
what's a what's big
there get in for and what see okay I'm
gonna give you 60 more seconds you
should be able to come up with an answer
for both these quiet let's do this
together this is something you gotta
nail down this is the basics of what a
two unit math student would do next year
like literally the basics so let me help
you what it looks like know what it
looks like this is my formula I'm going
to encourage you to quarter as much as
possible until such point as you don't
need to quote it and you can work out
what all the numbers are just by doing
the substitution in the first line
hey Arian maybe don't speak while I'm
speaking thank you
I've written it down just to make sure I
don't get confused as I do the
substitution in because I've seen a few
of you some of you for instance have a
calculator error the reason why is
because you've got confused in the way
your substitution
let me show you I quote the formula and
now I begin substituting if you have to
do what I've done up here and label each
of the numbers so you know what is what
the less that you need to hold on to in
your brain the less chance there is for
silly errors minus B is the first thing
I supposed to write down so what was B
again B it already has a negative sign
on it so this negative sign will cancel
become positive so the first thing I'll
write down is 4 plus or minus comes next
the square root of B squared well now I
actually don't need to worry about the
negative because you square it and get
16 then comes minus 4ac now this step
here watch out for this is what has
caused some people to come and start -
for what a it's positive 3 but C is that
negative - it's not - right so again
just like earlier you're going to get a
double negative this is one of the
things that's hard about the quadratic
formula you get double negatives here
and here but that's part of what happens
when you use this formula so watch out
for those two a what's - a in this case
it's 6
so I've done almost substitutions and
now I just need to simplify as best as I
can Falls already as simple as it gets
inside the brackets that's gonna be 12
times 2 which is 24 yeah
16 plus 24 is that okay to do in your
head I think we're okay with that 46 is
already as simple as it gets but at this
point is there anything I can do to make
this a little detail yeah you look at
this surd and you think I can take a
square number out of that what's the
biggest square you can fit four will do
the job right so I'm going to take out
the square root of four what it what is
the square root of four it's two once
you take out the square root of four
what gets left behind the square root of
10
okay so that looks good there's a six
down so now it looks like I've got a
common factor on the top and bottom of
two so I'll divide everything by two and
I don't think we can go any further what
do you think if I wanted to after this
or maybe on the next line if I didn't
already have something written there I
could say therefore x equals the first
solution there's one of them or the
second solution there's the other
there's the plus or minus however do you
remember I did point out there's a time
when it's useful to do this and a lot of
the time you don't have to where would
you do this what would you separate it
out I always can but where it's most
useful is suppose I didn't have the
square root of ten here suppose I had
the square root of 100 you wouldn't
write that it's a squared 100 would you
what would you replace it with you just
replace it with the number 10 well if
this is 10 and this is 10 then there's
more simplifying I can do right so then
I'll separate them out but here like the
thirds stay thirds and you can't do
anything else so I think this is fine
okay thumbs up all right now one last
quick note on this one that's have a
look at it this is 95% and answer that
works however there's one tricky little
problem and I wonder if any of you have
spotted it it says write an equation
with solutions x equals 1/2 or de- 2 now
what is a solution like you found
solutions up here there they are right
what is a solution what does that even
mean a solution is a value right like
say that or for that and if you put it
into the original equation it makes a
true statement so if I took 3 minus root
10 on 3 and I plugged it into all of
these all of these spots then it should
equal 0 okay on the left hand side 0
equals 0 it's true however in this case
if I put in x equals 1/2
I'll get 1/2 here that becomes 0 it
doesn't matter what this is because 0
times whatever
zero so I get y equals here now is that
a true statement well might be I have no
idea what Y is okay so actually what I
want to be on the left-hand side is not
actually why it's just zero you see
because that's what happens when you put
in the x equals 1/2 you'll get 0 and if
you put in x equals negative 2 over here
you'll get 0 so very minor difference
like I said there's 95% there but that's
what I would write you could get a
different one you could have written
this that would have also given you the
same solutions but I just asked for an
equation so anything you gave me is fine
or you would you have to expand it well
let me ask you this do you feel like
this has answered the question is it an
equation yes does it have these
solutions yes if they asked us to expand
like explicitly then yes better I'm I'm
happy with them okay